so what I wanted to do here is bring you
all the story of how deadpool managed to
wield the hammer of thor and the whole
reason behind this is that in truth
there's no deep philosophical meaning or
anything to this in fact the only reason
why I really want to do this story is
because it's really fun
so if you recall my previous videos on
the history of Deadpool we had talked
about how Joe Kelly had taken over the
character in 1997 and launched a solo
series however following Joe Kelly's
departure the title was handed over to
Christopher priest and where Deadpool
had indirectly broken the fourth wall a
couple of times under Kelly priest had
made this a mainstay of his character
making Deadpool far goofier and paving
the way for the version that we know
today and priest took to giving us crazy
scenarios which helped to beef up the
popularity of the character but also
allowed Deadpool to parody existing
superheroes and to this end and Deadpool
Volume one issue number 37 a priest
wrote a story titled benediction
appearing to Deadpool and claiming to be
his father Loki it hashed a scheme that
would allow him to D power Thor leaving
lovely the opportunity to take over
Asgard without for his interference due
mistress death playing a large role on
the life of Deadpool and that the two of
them have had romantic meetups as some
that we've discussed in great depth in
previous videos the Loki seemingly
kidnaps mistress death and places her
under a spell akin to Sleeping Beauty
while death will appears to simply be
playing along with Loki scheme this
comic also serves the purpose of moving
Deadpool's breaking of the fourth wall
away from something that was simply
comedic to the moment in which Deadpool
realizes that he's actually a comic book
Wallis only subtle and Deadpool doesn't
make a huge fuss of it he's informed by
Loki that there's actually a man on a
typewriter writing out his stories again
this is extremely short and Deadpool
cuts Loki off before we can finish but
for many fans this highlights one of the
most important moments for the character
in the transition from Kelly's Deadpool
to priest Deadpool
so the story jumps forward to Thor as
he's dealing with a fire in a building
and helping to save those who were
trapped with Deadpool arriving and
having been assigned by Loki to steal
Thor's hammer
Deadpool watches the events unfold but
also has some reservations about what
he's seen from Deadpool's perspective
Loki may very well have been cast out of
Asgard and it makes sense that his
frustration over this would be the
driving force behind his actions but
even if Odin is responsible for the
nature of his son to some degree Loki is
responsible for his own actions however
during tours attempt to save lives
an explosion occurs causing him to drop
his hammer because Thor will return to
his human alter-ego if he doesn't pick
up the hammer again within 60 seconds
deadpool takes the opportunity to begin
hunting for Mjolnir while Ford does the
same thing with 60 seconds passing and
Thor returning to his form of donald
lake deadpool manages to find the hammer
commenting on the fact that he never
really liked thor due to the fact that
thor had everything deadpool didn't in
the form of women wooing over him as
well as his beauty and incredible
strength deadpool manages to pick up the
hammer to the surprise of thor himself
and from here we transition to deadpool
having the time of his life while
wielding Thor's hammer at one point he
stops a Taco Bell and orders 37 gorditas
why he does this or what this has to do
with the powers of Thor are completely
unknown although this is probably
because the gorditas are amazing next he
goes to a theme park and uses the hammer
on one of their attractions what I also
like to mention here is that being a
comic story and tried this while we were
in Dallas and he didn't do very well the
next action the Deadpool is shown to
take is to take the hammer to a baseball
game where he smashes the ball out of
the park
how Deadpool is able to walk onto the
field of a baseball game while it's in
progress is never explained
and so both simply just chalk this up to
it being part of a Deadpool comic
appearing in Avengers mansion and
meeting mom avoid the front gate with
his arms full of Michael Jackson CDs the
Deadpool attempts to convince Marvel boy
that he's actually the real Thor at this
point Donald Blake arrives where he
joins Marvel boy in his attempt to to
subdue Deadpool with the CDs flying
everywhere one of which is thriller the
best Michael Jackson CD of all time
Donald Blake a Deadpool are whisked away
to the lair of Loki and coming to the
realization that Loki was basically
tricking him the whole time although
it's not explained whether Deadpool
actually believed that Loki was his
father or not
Deadpool turns on the villain hitting
him with his hammer the setting Donal
blake free and returning Milner to him
metal blade tries to pick up the hammer
but actually fails in the process with
Loki mocking Donal Blake over his
inability to lift his own hammer and
presumably being unworthy Deadpool tries
to offer a distraction but is swiftly
defeated and so after Loki departs Thor
begins to realize what's actually going
on here ordering the group to return to
Earth we learned two things the first is
that the owner had been sitting in the
wreckage of the earlier explosion the
entire time but was made invisible
presumably by Loki then picking it up
and returning back to his normal for
forum we also learned the second thing
the hem of the Deadpool had picked up
wasn't the real mule near and presumably
using his magic to fabricate a hammer
that had all the same attributes as the
hammer for - the enchantment of
worthiness as was placed on it by Odin
dental and picked it up believing
himself to truly be worthy and to
actually become a version of for
stripping his hammer away from him and
declaring him to be a false god the Thor
and Deadpool actually engage in a fight
with one another after deadpool declares
at Livia's right and that thor is
arrogant and haughty deadpool states
that he's actually going to teach thor
some humility
at which point four takes both hammers
and smashes them together against
Deadpool's head coming to the
realization that this might be is cue to
leave the story ends with deadpool
simply just returning home
now because of the fact that this was a
part of an ongoing series that is to say
part of Deadpool vol 1 and it wasn't
really a standalone series the only
people who were buying this story at the
time in reading it were those who were
already existing Deadpool fans and so
for the most part I haven't really been
able to find any information regarding
whether or not this story was popular
among the mainstream of course with
Deadpool fans we know that it was
popular because they were reading it but
among those who were not reading
Deadpool stories because they weren't
purchasing it there's really no
information to go on here with that
being said we're gonna bring this video
to an end and I will catch you guys on
it
very still
you